yah hello welcome to this broadcast I
really hope I'm life yeah we have this
thing again I need to ask it that really
life last week was one of those cases we
have software telling me all is fine and
great but I wasn't life so I have to
have to ask okay how are you everything
then in the chat channel I hope you had
a good weekend and a good monday i think
in many countries this monday was a um
was a holiday so um yeah cool thanks for
telling me that I'm really on so let's
get going down a five minute okay
cassoulet with black yeah and I'm going
to say it right away i'm going to play
gambit mode today playing sharp stuff
hope for the best so let's see what
happens do we get a gambit stein opening
here hmm only not have these three is a
little bit little bit too slow to get
very sharp but maybe he is allowing me
for quick g5 business isn't okay maybe i
can get in Long castles yeah which is
kind of unusual but interesting really
night to h4 this is a move why can I not
take e for now this is what I'm curious
about hmm okay nighty form
night if five
I don't get it I'm taking I don't get it
what happens here that's a question why
don't I have icc mouth move sounds on
for the stream this is the the way I'm
ICC has it set up for their for their
own streams this is nothing that I I
influence okay queen bee three um yo e6
hangs maybe I can just go here Queen B
seven looks totally wrong so it just
blunders the Queen after rugby eight and
I'm threatening you okay right now I
have the open-air found not just the
pond it's also a nice position that
looks very nice actually I'm threading
Bishop f2 as well for Bishop back to
Andrew gave a check there's someone
requesting the to play the Latvian at
least once um no nope I think I really
should make a video on why the Latvian
is such a crab opening so rookie have
three here I guess you know that looks
quite good winning a second porn and I'm
threatening rookie evade so let's see
here the question really is if I have
something better but probably not let's
just take take here and go for the
endgame it's really it's really enough
this kind of this kind of advantage I'm
getting the night over to f6 to attack
the e4 pawn he has a weakness only for
so let's attack it that looks good two
points to the good
yeah knock on the table while making the
movement would be fun right yeah thanks
for the happy birthday wishes i got my
birthday yesterday some thanks guys so d
5 or not i wonder if i should just try
to attack the Pawnee a second time on
night over to foil it or actually also
nice there are books on the Latvian the
others i think one book maybe some wood
a book but only one relatively recent
book and it's just a rubbish opening and
yeah maybe maybe I should do a ref
refute the rubbish opening kind of video
ok so we could get to a rook endgame now
which cannot be bad still two pawns and
he corrected let's say my pawn structure
problem there yeah like to get in g4
here so g4 right away or I can also
prepare it with root g8 why not that's
not a position where you where you need
to need to rush things in particular can
also do this first so that after see if
I they have d 50 hear ya look the eight
and d5 is probably easiest there are two
books on the Latvian gambit yeah I mean
it's really a shame about the rainforest
gem and they really use the rainforest
to produce paper and for the Latvian
gambit right unbelievable
um you can refute the Latvian gambit you
really can okay um speaking of
refutation I think this is kind of
pointless that you continuous am but ok
intending to take now just covering this
yeah that's just in March the pawns for
up to two
let's see what is them and what's the
easiest yeah maybe still this sound
that's for Luke 22 and then go back with
the king that that is easiest
hmm i don't know i can go give to some
plan Jim so pretty simple there were no
no famous player ever played the Latvian
gambit someone says they are much worse
opening than the Latvian gambit um I
don't know it's pretty bad Oh f3 is also
pretty bad shouldn't do that one so
let's see maybe just move the rook first
yeah to the side and then go f3 that
seems okay f3 for Luke h1 mate looks
good yep and he resigned yeah there was
a nice nice start mmm graco yeah well
this is from the 16 16th century this is
quite quite a long long time ago okay so
let's see yeah someone says to f6
instead of f5 for that units probably
worse actually argue that I think f5
might be in verse but okay um any
thoughts on ye the 15 year old Chinese
jam yeah it seems to be very strong yeah
227 25 or something at age 15 that's
pretty good so if we probably will see
and hear more of them okay so let's see
what kind of thing can I get here
against the French is difficult to play
again but this is a gambit line actually
yeah like this and then G form which is
really crazy so I'm going to go for that
come on so G form talk about a crazy
opening why is it Queenie to it might be
confusing things
I actually did confuse things I think we
need two is better first but it did
irritate him he's thinking when will
anyone beat manga skulls yeah maybe ye i
don't know but to be honest i am only so
like two or three games of ye that I
really looked at in a little bit um yeah
a little bit more detail so i really
cannot tell you that much um yeah so i
cannot tell you like okay you know and
this in that game we play grade and so
on i really cannot do that I never
looked at his games in in much detail
just one or two okay this actually looks
quite nice forward right this isn't this
a good position down if I go Queen h5
that already looks a bit dangerous you
can go to f4 though yeah but still it
looks like the right move Knight f4
night a for Queen edge fire looks okay
Wow f5 really hmm okay I'm taking that
Knight f6 if he goes rook f6 I
understand yeah that's made on d 2 but
if I let's say if I take a chick with
the bishop let's say until Knight f3 I
can still maybe take with them red
okay let's do this the bishop is just
too strong there rook takes and now this
for Bishop d3 I come on let's stop the
Latvian gambit nonsense if Karis and
Spassky played the Latvian gambit there
were probably just drunk that's a that's
probably the reason okay um talking
about drunk what did what did this guy
do to his position isn't he just getting
checkmated down I think this paid off
okay yeah Rubinstein we did not mention
him yet yep but now I did yeah what
about this he cannot defend their right
how is he not getting checkmated they're
going to g6 now or I also have night age
3 which is kind of good just getting
another piece into the attack bin g6 is
not bad Queen g4 is not bad but let's
let's put this night on h3 getting this
temple must be fine there's a question
there do I have students outside of
Germany I most of my students outside
Germany I have two or three German
speaking and like yeah much much more
more english-speaking students okay rook
g2 that looks like a that's actually a
decent triad a defense huh how do I win
now
Luke g1 probably Bishop t2i play King be
one so ignoring that I can just take
actually
hmm Luke g2 was a good defense but I
don't see a moon now if he he trades
like butchy one look g1 this this is
certainly going to be made and he cannot
cover the rock I mean queen now he
resigned yeah that's simply too much
this is a funny funny opening line b3
here this be three but yeah I think it's
probably not the most sound the sound is
line ever but it's funny can be played
in blitz chess I actually when I was
playing the French I usually didn't even
take on e4 I just played Knight f6 in
this position declining everything
getting to a normal French position okay
so next game there it works quite well I
with this with this somewhat strange
openings I don't get a game there okay
and someone aya green day 27 let's see I
think he's an e4 player so okay guys
just one time I'm going to try it yeah
i'm going to try it and and see how this
guy is going to crush me d 4 is already
second right right okay it's it's not
not the best best way to play against
the opening not bad but not the
reputation is blundering please I'm
sorry and I'm bashing this opening left
and right and this guy just blunders a
piece on move 5 ah you're supposed to
refute it okay so what what am i doing
now
um Bishop g4 maybe yeah let's go Bishop
g4 trying to try to win this with an
attack I was thinking Queen age for here
but maybe this is not really on let's
start with the chick stinking Queen h4
but Queen f2 isn't isn't that clear take
stakes it's not that clear 96 is
interesting really going all out for the
attack then I deform ok ok that's funny
ok I probably had some simpler ways to
to do this but that was interesting so
Kim here for rookie aid
and have 94 94 Andrew piayed yeah the
best movers three simply 395 and white
is much better now this is funky a
rookie eight is a threat 94 as a threat
and it's not so clear what is movies I
really don't don't see one a good one
maybe maybe Bishop Bishop before I can
still play rupee eight tricky so cringe
to us what you did mmm so check only
eight is going for kinky one hmm how am
i meeting him then it really looks like
there should be a maid night 94 it's not
that clear it looks good to start with
the move here and now kinky 10 am i
winning here Queen Queen d4 is also not
bad maybe but I don't see a maid
I don't see a maid in this position
which is kind of strange and I dijo is
not doing the job guidi for looks kind
of strong but still I don't see a maid
and here text this here on g4 hmm I
cannot move the bishop I made on mated
on g7 yeah okay let's take that I really
don't have more time here to him don't
have the time to think about this more
really I was thinking okay I was
thinking Queen Queen was better but okay
I have hum Queen takes bit too with a
very serious threat now maybe he can go
King see one no I can take d2 looky one
check and King see 294 Jeremy I can take
twice I don't know if that wins that I
can take okay let's do that Roxy wonders
rook takes the tool or queen a free
check
why it's not so quick avid quinta 3 is
right Queen f3 and now let's see going
to antique here yes got the Bishop
Bishop d3 as such as a problem there I
know Bishop b3 and I don't have a they
don't have a spot for my queen
unbelievable char okay I am NOT default
check
nonsense he to check no I can check him
here actually wow I'm very slow guys on
tactics wow I won this I won this game
that was wild that was wild ah crazy
crazy okay so um next one I have to play
a little bit more solidly yeah there's a
question what's the best line against
the Leningrad Dutch yeah that would be
very very interesting to know to me as
well there is nothing that great in
particular against the Leningrad
actually it's it turns out to be quite
okay in recent GM practice I actually
try to play early deviations against
them against the Dutch like 293 or
Bishop g5 simply because I don't feel
what has that much has that much room in
the main lines but then the mainland
seems to be quite okay I think it was a
wild game yeah I wasn't wasn't was fun
if you win it's it's always a bit of fun
but it wasn't really necessary um didn't
for meter for him to him to lose it um
an interesting line against the landing
at dutchess with an early before ya like
like d4 g3 Bishop g2 93 and beef is
quite interesting black seems to be K
there as well but it's not not that bad
okay so what do we get now I get the
Kings oops the King's gambit of course
as we said it's gambit time and he is
declining the Kings gambit okay that's
not the most testing line against it but
it's not so bad Bishop g4 it's h3 the
rivals there are some crazy lines here
Jake sticks cream is this right I don't
know I really don't know 94 if he goes
94 Queen g3 isn't this a nice in this a
line I think everyone is right actually
here I don't know I never declined the
Kings gambit it's just not the best
reply it seems the toilet variation has
mentioned yeah that's the line of the
Sicilian someone mentions 95 might be
right yeah that's possible I really hmm
I have no idea Kings gambit declined is
something I don't know I wonder what
he's doing here I mean you cannot he
cannot not take do you want to retreat
the bishop there or is there some kind
of weight check I'm connected and here
he is also connected so what what is
your point him um there's a question how
much yellow is to be considered a
grandmaster in in over the board play
the typical ero rating for GM is for
2500 and upwards um in the
if we think about this this rating here
the ICC five minute um what I'm having
here like 2400 is usually constituting a
good average GM strength I'm better at
blitz than than I am in and regular over
the ball tournament play so he took on a
form that cannot be the best line just
simply put 90 form is always a question
here what am i doing then I can go back
maybe here I even will go back to the
one yeah that's interesting at its Queen
g3 a good move or not Mia you would like
to play the move but is it really the
right move hard to say i'm NT s night h5
as well not just the fork on g2 ok let's
gamble there I cannot really yeah I am
it's ok yeah okay if it takes f for
Queen takes I'm threatening on f7 of
course he can just let say castle now
that's possible what still night c 2
iron I'd see two kinky to Bishop e3 is
kind of embarrassing but what about
night see to King you one ok doesn't
matter he did not go for it so I'm going
to casa long now the only thing I have
to be really aware of its night e to
will win my queen so this is something
that I should not allow um yeah maybe
King King to be one yeah he's got he's
getting some quick quick pants up there
yo that's is that is a bit of a problem
here ha 84 is a good news
so I probably have to play with this
attacking f-cell an a4 I just take f7
and okay I'm in an awkward pin but I
cannot worry about that at the moment I
want this time this gain of time yeah
it's a question do you think that there
should be another official feeder title
after GM um I actually don't think that
this is a great idea to get this I don't
know super GM or something like that um
I think it's kind of pointless to be
honest you have to you have a rating
system which pretty accurately reflects
how good people play and those titles um
that they are quite nice but in general
like GM and so on but I don't really see
a point for adding a point in adding
another title um I mean people really
look at reading mostly and if you see an
IM with 2,500 2,500 50 or something he's
probably just a better player than a GM
with 2 450 yeah the same as yeah rating
means a lot if if people really play
quite often so it's a pretty accurate
way of describing their playing strength
so I don't really think we need to be
need more titles they're also there are
those titles on it on a lower level yeah
those like candidate master and and and
what do not and I don't really don't
really think we need more of those as
well I mean where do you want to start
with you know the rules gets a title or
something I don't really know know about
that what a bad night then yeah I was I
was intending to just block the FR but
it's a terrible p.m. well it wasn't a
good idea probably ok the only thing
that's really in my favor is the time I
played some strange move but I played
them quick
um Queen 37 now let's double them the
only thing that I have here is the air
file and it's not doing that much in the
first place now there's someone asking
for the landing-grid dutch yeah why not
this is a this is a interesting opening
and also as I said it's just just a good
opening nothing to be said nothing wrong
about it and I've played the landing
with Dutch in tournament chess oh
absolutely yeah the the Queen trade I
don't know about my king is also not
very safe okay so he's not allowing
Queen trade at the moment so Luke g3
maybe I can do something he might take a
4 and b3 check or something like that
huh I hope that my position really sucks
IAM to be honest yeah I if they go d4
and if they go d4 i will play i will try
out the leningrad touch some way there
too ok let's start with that and then
maybe look fo as an idea rook takes a
force irritating me but it's probably
not that dangerous yeah that's
interesting now I get in night to be six
this was something that I saw a couple
of minutes a couple of moments ago that
this improves my night all of the Sun
quite considerably now I'm not bad in
this position Oh brow I can check out
only six now
and and his Queen doesn't have many
squares so probably the check is good
check and here for poking let's say you
know I asking him about the week back
rank so I cannot play 96 as this is
covered hmm
hmm
don't see a clear way here actually here
there's route chief formal right I
thought and look g3 just piling up as
possible it seems like it's possible we
should be too maybe I Bishop b2 might be
on there should be two might be possible
and now it's going there I thought I can
play 96 now 49 f7 still trying to play
good moves I mean I would probably win
on time but still trying to be correct
him I think I'm winning with neither 7
but still so tricky yeah chances to play
the slim & Gamble yeah of course I would
would play that if they allow it they
play the rip I already played the
Latvian right i mean the latvian is kind
of the slimmin gambit on drugs right so
let's see what happens now you get I got
a good it could school here right with
those wacky openings but that was was a
shaky game and definitely go in trouble
him
the sodium opening what is the sodium
opening I don't know that one yeah
waiting for new gay me I have the
request out for a new blitz game but
don't get one yet oh yeah say do now
with black okay I was close to playing
the Latvian again yeah after D for you
don't really have a gambit approach I
you know this is a wacky line twin to H
for the Steinitz line which is normally
leading to problems for black but let's
give it a look at let's give it a try I
think they take yeah I think they cheek
then takes on c3 and king d 8 or
something which is really crazy the bad
thing about this is that in fact it's
Wyatt who's doing all the attacking so
it's not a gambit by black but but
rather very risky porn porn porn grab
let's see can I defend this looks very
scary night here maybe yes dinettes
really played this kind of stuff he was
a really a weird person sometimes this
really takes a strong sense for
masochism to play for completely for one
pawn you're sitting there and the other
guy is kind of firing bullets at you all
of the time really a strange way to play
but okay I was I wanted something else
today here we go um what is this if I
take on c3 is this too risky it looks
very risky 93 be takes well it's another
porno
Oh bishops is six at the point i had
looks that looks very very dangerous if
i just take it may be taking it is
easier I mean easy as wrong better maybe
this is just better in fact this doesn't
look so so we're shaky at least the
default is closed
so he wants to check on f6 probably it's
gorgeous d 6 Bishop f5 and so um the
sodium is ch4 h h fry for and now I
don't know that kind of things it's
really too too bad um okay so Queen f4
is probably an idea here for hun I see
em yeah she I'd like to play Bishop f5
but that's not really helping Queen a
form maybe just age six making sure he
actually takes
yeah this son I was thinking that this
might be just the best for him so I was
thinking Queenie 644 Queen f5 next just
consolidating yeah that's the bad thing
about section opening at you're under
fire and you're so glad that you are not
getting checkmated you happily give back
pawns yeah one or two pawns and yeah you
feel good about it yeah that you're not
immediately losing so Queen jf five if
he takes it Bishop e7 rupee eight Bishop
c6 hmm rupee one takes them that looks
bad really looks bad so what am I going
to do like c6 or something c6 Kings 27 I
just got d5 maybe this one well the
Scandinavian opening yeah the
Scandinavian is pretty okay the the
reason why it is not played in top-level
chairs and said it's very difficult to
equalize with it completely but black is
not in bad shape it's just in most lines
it's a slight advantage but nothing
nothing in particular bad about it so
I'm in let's say normal people Chester
you can easily play the Scandinavian
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
that if people play let's say out the
super GM level they simply they will run
into some kind of preparation and this
is some something they want to avoid and
what is this is he really giving this up
you give us giving me the exchange down
and now look here okay yes you can check
me
so what am I going to do here I would
like to really can I had somewhat trap
is queen or something Queen f5 or
something look where I don't know let's
do that let's start with the move his
rook is detect hmm my pieces are not all
coordinated this is this is a real
problem I wonder if no it's not an idea
cannot attack the rook easily here looky
seven would be nice but cannot really
play it and this is actually trading
Queens because Queenie one is a threat
so then I should do that let's trade
Queens his age porn is dangerous but
yeah you cannot have it all what is he
doing training Quintus the only move
otherwise is getting checkmated as he
allowing the maid down that would be
nice makes things much easier nope he
didn't fall for the mid okay so let's
see going King up to f6 and go from
there how am i winning this mmm be six
maybe b6 and c5 then rook trade would be
nice it's good that the H point H point
is not super quick in advancing so
probably rook to e8 what's he doing rook
to a3 or something I can also do this
for rookie one and then rookie seven if
he plays rook a three it should be fine
and then trying to attack B and C porn
from the back one down to a minute okay
so um yeah yeah there are many openings
that are playable on the on the top
level yeah with with like one off yeah I
just played once and just for a surprise
value in with that mindset you can play
many openings as someone mentioned
magnus carlsen even played the pond
siani opening which is also not
promising very much but it's good enough
for a surprise surprise in your
repertoire maybe yeah I think I'm
winning the dip on now or not think I am
so I weathered the storm here with this
wacky line okay now he has he has some
killed his own Bishop down on on c6 or
on b5 now let's see look II to know then
c 5s coming how is how am i winning this
oh my time oops wow I should play
quicker that's the way to win it I've
got 18 seconds I totally forgot about
the time I now when I'm blundering at
five and this he played that so badly
area so badly it's a shame it's a real
shame unbelievable
going for trying for oops got this chick
seven seconds now yeah I killed myself
such an idiotic move giving away f5 am
just totally I forgot about the time I
simply forgot about the time this is
such a simple wynia I just have to avoid
exactly what what I what I allowed you
can just play at any move f4 whatever is
just a piece down on b5 basically just
more just bad okay so let's see there's
a question about the viewer games
revolute note it is not all hold a
lovely I simply have a time problem at
the moment I cannot do that much in
terms of videos the thing is so i'm i'm
off for a longer journey in them in the
summer and i'm producing many videos of
blitz chess for the channel and doing
more is difficult i really have more
than enough material for the viewer
games i actually prepared two of those
videos but didn't didn't record them yet
so it is not it is not gone this series
at all but it's um at the moment i don't
i don't get to it much so this is them
this is the UM Smith Mora gambit and I
think this guy what is he doing here
isn't this isn't this very risky he's
not developing stuff what about 95 is
this is this on noises totally crazy
let's do this first and then thing
about it 95
95 cheeks moons not going to work so
probably h5 edgewise 5s is the way to go
if he takes it to me which I we take
with the pawn I don't want that yeah i'm
doing a longer journey there in the
summer play I'm going I'm going for two
weeks to relax in Slovenia which is my
preferred place in the summer and i'm
also going to play a bit of chess
playing an open event in in poland and
also are we briefly going to the czech
republic for some chess so let's see
night I wanted to do 95 them that all
looks wrong what I did here it looks
wrong hmm if I take it now you can take
with the porn even that's absolutely no
compensation okay maybe I have to go for
a shoot fire for someone is asking um
who would you like to qualify to the
next candidates yeah I don't know um I
mean what is clear the thing is the only
clear participant is Vicki Allen I think
because of the loser of the last is
loser of the last verge championship
match I think Caruana is also qualified
now with them with the with this
performance now at the Grand Prix and I
think Nakamura is also very close to
qualify I think he needs to not lose
against them against Jack Vanko in the
final round with white which seems
doable but those does not have to lose
in the final round is also a tricky
business so
so I'm still has to do it first by the
way what I'm playing here is the most
unsound stuff ever that looks like
complete complete nonsense but okay if I
was I would have wanted something
something sound I would have started
night of three on the first move this is
at least a kind of funny it's like a
drunken machine gunner chess you just
kind of firing away and hope you hit
something if this is a politically
correct term probably not yeah I don't
know I'm definitely in bad shape here
but he has to refute it first so like f6
right let's go f6 Bishop takes I'm going
to smash the exchange for 94 that might
even be some compensation it's not
completely completely wrong
well I don't know that's probably no
good but how does he exactly win now you
can put night only three Bishop e3 check
but this no no this is winning I'm not
sure about it at least he's very
irritated it seems in fact you can argue
that there is no threat here I mean
taking on g7 it's not like winning
easily but what now if it moves the
night okay he goes back so um I can play
a couple of things am probably starting
with taking is good and Knight g4 maybe
next like 94 for the pin there's no real
pen going on I don't see three it's not
doing anything I think I'm playing this
movie getting out of this checks this
makes many things more dangerous here
getting out of the checks and then go
from there if my night here was kind of
playing the knight on c3 that would be
interesting my chief formed
okay let's do that there's a question do
you ever travel to North America Canada
I'm very interested really very
interested for chess but also form for
the nature yeah like the national parks
and so I would be very interesting
problem is I really really hate flying I
really do and those longer flights are
kind of put up for me I don't know have
to think about this okay this I don't
have to think about or do i roped you
six look T 694 look 26 naija form this
is really really a problem hooked you
694 how do I don't have a move there
that's kind of kind of shame takes high
I think he overlooked that but it
doesn't it doesn't win there's something
else I can take e 5 hmm look t6 naija
form isn't that a way to make that work
look the eight Queen takes g3
unfortunately
hmm this is threatening it it said sets
very crude yeah now it's not even
threatening it what a nonsense move that
doesn't make any sense at all I can
still not play rook takes t6 this is
just just totally wrong he's probably
completely irritated now hear about this
move which is just totally totally weird
um yes f6 that's a good defensive move
okay maybe died to h3 and then take the
bishop or something that's just a
totally bad game Bishop H true that was
completely bad yeah you can get on a
boat I actually looked at that you are
traveling to North America on the on
ships but unfortunately unfortunately I
also hate peeing on ships the only kind
of travel that i like is is why a
trainer or why accom really yeah but
okay I actually considered that the ship
the way and doing it on ownership but
yeah it also kind of expensive what is
he doing he just loses on time there now
we resigned that's strange yeah he was
so irritated by my wiki play probably
that he lost some time Bishop hua as
someone is laughing at Bishop a show
you're right you're totally right about
that it was crap ok now let's play
against grandmaster Ricciardi and he
knows how to refute the latvian if not
i'm kind of i don't know i don't know
what i'm going to do a fee he also plays
d for guys learn the reputation it's not
so difficult just 93-5 come on okay this
is also not bad night c4 is also quite
good but the other line is just much
better
so d6 ok there's a question what do I
dislike so much about flying you just
hate being in a plane yeah I hate being
in a plane I always feel I just feel bad
it's not about the plane crashes really
I mean this is not something that that
helps very much with the bed feeling
while being on a plane but um it's just
that um I just feel very just feel very
unwell being on a plane yeah just it's
not not not the kind of thing where you
have to use those little baggies that
they give you it's not that I have to
puke or whatever it just I just don't
feel well yeah and actually have a good
position here I mean at least not a bad
position which is kind of weird don't
you guys ever look at of bid openings
like the Latvian that's crazy that's
really crazy yeah exact angle and we
cannot pronounce that anxiety yeah yeah
I feel I just feel bad just feel bad
yeah those vibrations on a plane they
they make me I know I hate it I really
hate it um I can do i do fly but not
those long distances they really seems
key seem scary to me I I I had to fly to
I don't know the UK or whatever slovenia
and so on yeah this is actually take
some drugs before getting on this is
actually what was recommended to me by
my by my mama doctor yeah yeah like okay
I can just prescribe you some pills and
you will just fall asleep like a stone
yeah nothing happens that that was a
funny approach but probably the right
one
and do I have a day job outside of chess
no I don't um I quit my regular day job
the office job about one year go a
little bit more than one year ago and
started to concentrate on being a chess
teacher and doing those commentary jobs
and so on yeah yeah someone someone says
they also hate flying yeah welcome i
really i really have to agree i also
hate the whole procedure they are like
you have to get to those you have to do
those security checks and the whole
thing it's kind of it's no fun but it's
what is he doing them in Bishop f4 or
whatever you should have many moves now
to be okay at least
I someone else am i aiming to get the GM
title no no not in particular I'm not
really am doing any any gun not doing
any training program or something to get
there so I'm just am playing I'm playing
I like to play games of course for my
club and so on but I'm not actively
trying to improve a lot to get to the GM
title I'm there's a question am I more
nervous playing a leak chess or
tournament chess where I'm just on my
own a much more nervous in league chess
because it's it's about the team yeah
you have to worry about the team
standings and so on ok g5 might be a bit
wacky but i think it's okay Quinn age 7
the next move so yet someone says I
actually hit someone says he likes the
planes but he understands fear of flying
yeah you know what's what's what's funny
and actually oh i blundered stuff wow
wow I totally blunder druke f6 while
chatting away oops oopsy-daisy yes yes
sir Sarah one often says huh and take
each for it takes d6 Wow
Wow poo that's bad I really had a nice
position out of this out of this crap
opening funny can after look F 2 can I
sacrifice for Queen D for something wait
check their IDs Queen III it's not
working what a shame the the Opera
office job that I had I was working in
finance at a bank yeah mostly yeah
counting spend money if you want
controlling it was mostly so what now I
think I think it looks it looks kind of
lost him Queen if I take with the Queen
maybe he has no check at the moment and
maybe Luke g6 is still still tricky hmm
it
Queen f4 he's got g3 doesn't help much
um no um that's a question about my 145
repertoire it is not completed and never
did the Italian game and the Rue La Paz
it's something that I will do if I have
the time it currently is on hold so um
yeah I'm a piece down but I don't like
to resign much let's continue I don't
believe it I can take son he can take on
g6 oh it wasn't it wasn't such an awful
mistake wait can I can I jerk him
somehow it's got 36 seconds it's not
that much I can take hear ya no I cannot
and it is just lost what can you do
shooting for age form okay so Bishop age
form he takes their couple of times cam
and rook rook g5 is completely
completely strange but maybe still for
work f5 okay so taking them it's got 96
coming now I can resign that it's just
too bad but that was that was awful and
I had such a good position but rook
takes f6 was a was a what a good thing
okay I'm going to play one more game
don't want to end with a loss one more
um what do we have yeah I wanted to say
something about flying on planar okay
that's not exactly about chess but um
what I wanted to say is the weird thing
is that i'm totally sure i would be
comfortable with flying if I would fly
myself if I would actually steer this
plane you know I feel I feel I would
have no problem whatsoever of course I
have no idea how to fly a plane but I
just feel that this would would be
totally fine for me but just sitting
there and don't know what's really going
on it's kind of strange um okay that was
bad what cakes have six modernized shot
though makes g5 completely wrong so I'm
shooting for another game they're going
a bit of overtime but but I'm I have fun
playing here so let's do one more game
okay that way I wanted to want it to get
the get the Leningrad going no I have no
ambition and have no ambition to to fly
a plane is just that I'm saying that I
feel that that this would be a different
thing h3 interesting maybe I can just
just play actively here and ignore the
fact that I have played f5 that looks
strange looks a little bit like a normal
position but I have f5 in but shouldn't
be that bad now that's not such a bad
position probably for black
I have still decent controlling over c5
so it should be okay now i'm not getting
nervous on a car when someone else is
driving it depends a little bit yeah i
mean i know some chess players they they
they drive like they just want to die it
is just like they have a death wish and
with those guys nobody would like to be
a be there in the in them let's say
copilot seat but with normal people I
really don't mind at all if they drive
and I'm sitting sitting there in the car
okay so going for 94 year there are some
people chess players chess players in a
car it's very particular a very very
strange there I've seen things really
like being in the car that are totally
unspeakable really um I was once driving
with one person to a to a league match
in in the Netherlands and he was he was
driving and I was sitting there on the
on the under on the cosi day on the
front seat and he was driving and he
missed her to take house is called yeah
you had to have to leave the the highway
there there the autobahn yeah and he
missed that yeah and it wasn't kind of a
complicated set up there but what he
just did is he just went right into
reverse gear gone back and and then then
left left left the highway I was like oh
no it was it was just it was insane it
was just like okay please kill me yeah
it was just like I have a death wish
unbelievable stuff unbelievable stuff so
I can only say be very cautious if you
want to yeah he missed the exit be very
cautious yeah with the chess players in
cars there can be there can be dangerous
people and yeah so this is not the the
greatest Dutch
ever yeah he did really got into reverse
key on the highway hmm it was it was
amazing it was amazing so I'm having
this this weird bishop against the night
which is a kind of the nightmare
scenario but it's not an automatic wind
still let's see i'm shooting for g5 rook
g7 okay yeah i know that looks it
doesn't look nice yeah yeah come on do
you want to go to see 5 or something
it's not clear that this is so great
actually okay okay I get some space on
the queenside all of the sudden I don't
mind to play on the queenside if he
allows it yeah this is so surprisingly
tough to kill this position even though
I'm definitely worse it's not it's not
like I'm losing straight away okay how
to do this now i can now cannot take
them
yeah now he really he really did did it
he duly a got into reverse gear on the
highway there was a situation with two
lanes and one lane was going on and one
lane was the exit and he really got back
to catch the exit it was crazy um but
but he also he did this guy he did many
things are not going to tell you the
name but he did many many crazy things
um let's see um so what is this he
actually allows Bishop g6 and the
capture maybe I should have a look at
the airport so that he cannot so easily
move the rook I American still move it
no yeah did this guy he also made them
he also traveled to the Netherlands for
another match and he had his some his
his his sat-nav set up incorrectly and
it was some guiding him to the place
correctly but avoiding all highways so
he was driving through a really far away
destination all on back roads this was
totally crazy it took like three hours
for a drive that should have lasted one
and a half hours and he got late to the
game of course but still could play yeah
yeah it's it's crazy sometimes
yeah I'm also not the most talented
driver i have to admit but at least i'm
not doing totally crazy things let's go
away there Knight takes e4 was a
potential idea yeah I'm still a bit
worse here but it's not not easy and
maybe I can really just take a five okay
covered that may be here just a Tekkit
yeah taking the scenic route that's
probably true it was probably nicer than
going via the the highway but if you are
you have to be on time yet for the
chesire game you cannot just be there
like it was just he was starting so
early that it didn't matter much but it
was it was crazy we were sitting in
their way see well Mason pissy not
arriving and while he took took the
scenic route um what am I appoints doing
there they are pretty playing very
slowly I'm one of the slowest players
but this is even even slower okay I had
to cover for him gem
his out form Queen to h4 maybe okay I'm
grabbing the pawn so Bishop g6 is its
asset so bad i really don't see the big
point there ok it's going to e7 for the
check only six maybe but that's not so
terrible i can takes you three
d 4 is hanging so okay that one I can
check it 1 C 1 and start to march maybe
still can take on g6 and I cannot move
the bishop because of 90 f 7 that's a
bit of a problem check
c3 maybe I don't know you can click
windy six maybe this isn't oh wow takes
Queen takes
don't give me that ah my queen has no
wedge again I cannot move my queen
anywhere i can go queen a three rookie
aid i'm lost year I don't believe it
that he will manage in three seconds so
can I move when I cannot do that
don't have a move their queen a three
rookie and really no way unbelievable
stuff I found might have seven do you
believe that okay so let's see if we can
make it on time he cannot yeah so okay I
well this kind of small this kind of
wacky openings i think justify a time
when they're okay yeah people voted for
flagging so i went for it okay so guys i
hope you enjoy this it had some some
crazy games and some good chat okay so
let's see next week i'll be on as well
and probably then maybe do something
something else not such crazy openings
maybe something a little bit more more
solid i hope you enjoyed it we also did
a little bit of overtime I think it was
it was good fun have a good week and
yeah see you next week bye bye